I want to start this week off by abiding
by one of the rules I set up when we
launched this operation I said that if
you guys fact-check me I would address
it on the show I did actually make a
minor error last week believe it or not
while talking to my guest Majnu Oz I
mistakenly said that Ben Carson was a
neuroscientist when in fact he's a
neurosurgeon that was really just a slip
of the tongue but a couple of you called
me out on it so I wanted to correct
myself of course at the end of the day
whether he's a neuroscientist or a
neurosurgeon one thing I hope he will
not become his President of the United
States we got a really great response to
our interview with Majid last week
actually when we finished I felt like
again we had been part of an important
conversation that needs to be had more
this of course is the irony of the
regressives that bash people like ma jet
and sam harris here you have two people
from very different walks of life trying
to promote secular values and
coexistence whether you agree with them
or not on every point is totally
irrelevant it should be obvious to
anyone with half a brain that these are
the guys trying to find a peaceful way
forward don't take my word for it though
listen to them speak themselves and by
the way you can disagree with them on
where they stand on certain issues yet
acknowledge that they're having a very
difficult dialogue on extremely heated
topics that most people are completely
afraid to have in the first place when a
journalist calls Maju to porch monkey
and sam a racist it exposes who the real
extremists are in case you missed it on
Friday nights real time Bill Maher had
an excellent sit-down with Richard
Dawkins on this new split on the Left I
was thrilled to hear Bill Maher actually
used the phrase regressive leftist bill
credited Sam Harris for coining the
phrase though from what I understand
Majid was using it as far back as 2012
in any event the fact that it trickled
up to Bill shows you that the
discussions we're having here on the
show as well as the ones that you guys
are having on Twitter and YouTube are
actually making a difference that's the
beauty of the internet you can get
issues to actually bubble up until
mainstream takes notice there's evidence
of the awakening that I've been talking
about all over the place right now on
Twitter someone asked me if by calling
these people the regressive left if I'm
just resorting to the same type of
name-calling that we accused them of my
answer to this is a hundred percent no
we're giving a name to a problem we've
all seen growing for a long time
now we can debate with them on facts if
they accept facts as such and not just
cherry pick them when suitable for their
narrative the reason I feel like naming
them is so important is because I now
view these regressives as the left's
version of the Tea Party the Tea Party
went unchecked by the right until it was
too late and now the Republican Party is
a fractured mess often only held
together by its worst beliefs
I really believe these regressive czar
doing this to the left and if we don't
have the courage to stop them then a
year or two from now we'll wonder why
our system has even screwed up more than
it is now that's why talking about all
this stuff is important and that's why
we're gonna continue to do so with that
out of the way it's time to sit down
with the outspoken Breitbart
conservative Milo a innopolis and fear
not I won't let any of his sift I
clogged a screw with my thinking my
guest this week is a writer for
Breitbart calm and a general rabble
rouser and Renaissance man Milo a
innopolis welcome to the show thanks so
much for having me so when I tweet it
out originally that you were coming in
half the people told me I was gonna
absolutely hate you half the people told
me I was gonna love you the first awful
wrong the first half wrong yeah all
right so so we actually had a drink the
other night want to be totally
transparent here we had a drink the
other night and we talked a little bit
so we've gotten to know each other
however much you can in an hour you are
a gay conservative mm-hmm and I want to
repeat that just so that the audience
can be clear you are a gay you think it
eats your PSA you think it's weird
conservative people why would that be
strange well people freaked out so let's
let's let's just start what is a
conservative to you in 2015 because I
think people don't even know what sort
of basic terms anymore much less the gay
part but let's just what is it
conservative I think the reason people
are surprised about a gay conservative
is because we have a slightly outdated
notion of what conservatism is now and
the religious right America doesn't have
the same purchase on the public
imagination anymore that it once did so
it's a sort of part of the right but not
whole of it and the right in Europe is
drifting quite quickly to the left so
depth of conservatism as a movement as
political philosophy is a bit lost at
the moment one thing we can say for sure
is that people on both sides of the
political spectrum are moving toward a
sort of center-right libertarianism and
for me the big gap
between people the the big sort of
defining political schism particularly
on the internet but I think of everybody
really is not left and right anymore
it's becoming between authoritarians and
libertarians the issue for the left
being that there isn't much space for
libertarians there a lot of
conservatives who you know don't know
are necessarily religious or find their
own party drifting to the left are
beginning to call themselves
conservative begin to call themselves
libertarians or conservatory and so I
think it's a more interesting
distinction to speak in terms of
personal liberty and freedom now and
when you understand it like that it
makes much more sense why gay person
would be one right so the part that we
sort of fall out on the same spot is the
authoritarian and libertarian part of
this right right we don't like the
authoritarians I think both of us are
sort of libertarians libertarians are
thought more of in the conservative
space but if you were to give me like a
three sentence synopsis of when you say
to someone I'm a conservative what do
you what are the principles there what
is what is the basic bullet principles I
think you believe in individual personal
responsibility you believe in freedom of
thought of expression of creativity you
believe in free markets you believe that
the relationship the individual the
state should be circumscribed quite
clearly and quite crisply so you believe
that the state has a limited and quite
well-defined set of responsibilities
beyond which it should not stretch you
believe in the power and value of
institution and authority and community
structures so you believe that even if
you may for example believe that even if
you're not a Christian you still
recognize that the church has something
to offer that is a valuable institution
that keep but likewise institutions like
monarchy you respect them because you
understand that even though for example
it will be very difficult to defend the
monarchy in purely logistical purely
logical terms these days nonetheless it
works best in Britain it is the best
system yet devised and it works
brilliantly in Britain even if you if
you were to design a state today you
wouldn't come up with it
conservatives instinctively understand
the the value of tradition and authority
and and of course liberals want to tear
all those things down so I think those
are some of the things that people mean
when they describe themselves the
conservative right so the reason I think
it's it's sort of a
using term or that all our terms have
become confusing I think is because a
lot of times now as you sort of alluded
to in America we think of conservatives
somehow as a detachment to the religious
right which is weakened a little bit
which i think is good and you're saying
in England it's a little more of a
respect for the monarchy monarchy has
respect for traditions but I think a lot
of people would say well you're just in
it for the man right well I think it's
preposterous so if you look at the
number look at how many working-class
conservative voters there are why would
all of these people be voting against
their own interests if that were true
you know if conservatism were really
about protecting rich people why would
millions of people who struggle to make
rent or struggle to put their kids
through college or struggle even perhaps
to you know to feed their families vote
conservative they do it because they
appreciate the value and some of the
structures around that they love and
they do it because they they believe in
a certain you know limit of the state's
power they believe in other things that
go with conservatism you why would so
many people vote against their interests
them is this absurd characterization is
a childish characterization of
conservatism to suggest that it is you
know in some way just a system to
protect them and protect the rich to
protect corporations I think we can all
agree that corporatism and mature late
capitalism which exists in sort of
intricate symbiosis with the private
sector and in some cases quite poisonous
in that respect the bailouts of the
banks in the UK the sorts of corporate
cronyism it happens in right of course I
think we can all agree that's a bad
thing but it is by no means restricted
to one side of the political spectrum
yeah well I always say there's a reason
that at least in America you know the 1%
give basically 51% to the Republicans
and 49% to the Democrats because they're
hedging their bets so yeah I don't
believe it goes down to either party no
and I don't you know if you if you take
the view that conservatism is about you
know sticking up for the man you have to
explain things like why conservatives
give more money to charity why even
conservatives who aren't religious give
more charity there are a lot of very
difficult questions you have to answer
if you want to make that argument for me
it doesn't hold water all right well
that's that's sort of where I wanted to
jump off from and just get a basic you
know a basic set of rules that we're
sort of talking about the most
interesting thing about yeah all right
now we're gonna get into some of the
interesting stuff so first thing I want
to ask you about is I think I found out
about you originally because of
gamergate that I've done one video on
gamergate it was about a year ago well
basically I said to the audience I said
I said guys look I don't really
understand this thing I don't know
what's going on here I have a sense it
has to do with some people that were
upset at some of the publications and
then all this daxing and all and
misogyny olessa but I basically said I
don't know so I don't know that I can
address it now you're in the thick of
this thing so I thought if we do one
thing on gamergate can we do like a five
minute really hash it out honest
everyone wanted to know what gamergate
was really about yeah it's five minutes
so for you yeah
we're all used to seeing these social
justice warriors you got a police
language you say that you know we're
gonna do plenty of strawberry random
things as sexist or racist or misogynist
or ever I think we're all used to now
the press in some cases reporting on
things extraordinarily badly now
gamergate has been a huge controversy of
people who care about these things
because both of those things have come
together it is a consumer movement that
rejects sloppy standards in reporting
about video games and video games by the
way we're a very important part of the
entertainment industry they're bigger
than Hollywood now 790 probably about by
now ninety billion dollar industry
rejects sloppy reporting about and there
all sorts of horrible infractions of
journalistic ethics and conflicts of
interests and we're just to stay on that
though for a second so basically the
game companies were sort of paying the
writers to give them better reviews that
is things like that going on if in
people sleeping with people and writing
things about them a bit too closely they
shouldn't have basically it's a very
fast growing industry so the press is
nascent the press has grown up very fast
and what was previously a trade press
you know like you know tree cutters
weekly or the stamp collectors monthly
or whatever has suddenly become a
consumer press and it hasn't necessarily
improved its standards commensurate with
that right the second half of it is the
social justice warriors who mentioned
briefly there is a sort of insurgent
move in video games from a couple of
whacky left-wing feminists cenizo sort
of far left Israel hating socialist
weirdos far left feminists who say that
everything every video game is
problematic that there's something wrong
with all these video games now for some
reason the journalists have sucked all
this up and have bought
the same journalists who protected
videogames when the religious right in
the 1980s and 90s said that videogames
turn kids into killers and violent
nature there's no evidence our prey we
know what's certain none whatsoever yeah
those same journalists nonetheless have
rolled over and accepted the feminist
critique of video games and said oh well
video games got me violent but they can
make you sexist now again there's no
evidence whatsoever that's the case yeah
the research is this the most generous
you could be is to say the research is
you know the jury's out yeah but most of
this most most of the most credible
research says there's nothing in it
right to be real clear on that so that
would be like for example in a game like
Grand Theft Auto where you can literally
grab a woman out of her car but you can
do that to a man - so you would you
would argue that that that's not well
the anti woman because they're there its
first of all it's right first of all
it's imaginary it's not real and second
of all it's on this computer screen
yeah and second of all what much of the
evidence shows actually is that people
who get stuff out of their system and
it's mainly boys who get the stuff out
of their system playing video games are
nicer to people in the real world
because it's that sort of boyish
testosterone thing I mean even as
homosexuals we have some understanding
of that male need to sort of win and
crush and you know and do that well you
know we you know you probably play
sports I don't but you know I take that
out horizontally but yeah there is there
is that sort of male need to get you
know get that sort of testosterone
energy out of the system and when boys
do that in video games much of the
evidence shows that they behave nicely
in real life now some if some studies
say that video games can make you hyper
competitive so the FIFA games the
football games you can leave somebody a
bit more competitive can raise the
testosterone levels but that's a very
temporary effect there's absolutely no
evidence whatsoever the video games can
make you sexist and these sorts of
cherry-picked insane feminists I mean
just just the most barmy bonkers Oliver
you know we'll get on to feminism later
but um it's coming if you imagine the
most wacky stereotypical blue-haired
overweight furious you know fact-free
terrible lesbian you know lesbionic
feminist well they're all lesbians now
lesbionic feminists kind of lunatic
that's the sort of person who's
criticizing videogames and very often
the people don't even play video
this is this is another chapter in the
culture wars which we're used to from
the movies and from books Morris - so
gamergate game ordinary gamers have put
up for 10 years or more with their own
press calling them man babies and
misogynists beating up on them basically
because it's the trendy thing to do
because these days progressivism and you
know sort of hating on men that kill all
white men kind of these feminists
hashtag are socially acceptable I mean
you you there is no you will get no
social censure from your peers as a as a
member of the media today for tweeting
one of those hashtags now obviously if
you did it the other way around it would
be a problem that's become fashionable
become trendy for white is this little
white guilt right white middle-class
skills become fashionable for these
people to beat up on themselves
prostrate themselves before the altar of
womanhood and say everything that they
are and everything that they do is
terrible I'm so sorry you know mother
Gaia how can I make it up to you
the reality is that actually these video
games quite good for people so that's
the crux of it then it's it's these
people it's the gaming community that
has risen up because it's been it is
tired of being lied about and slandered
by its own press press they did a really
good job of defending it when the
violence stuff is going on Jack Thompson
in the 90s were saying videogames can
make you violent the press did a really
good job of rebutting him yes he was
conservative but when a liberal when a
progressive critic comes along they fall
over themselves to agree and start
hating on their own audience right and
that's really interesting and it goes to
really what 90% of what we're gonna talk
to talk about is about because right I
remember when when Joe Lieberman who's
you know was on the right at that time I
guess he's an independent now when he
was railing against violence in video
games with Mortal Kombat I remember it
was very cool to say what what a loser
he was and so out of touch
well the problem with some the problem
of video games probably gamers is they
have no social capital everybody hates
them the right hates video games because
it says they cause school shootings and
because they're violent and a bit and
deviant and dorky
and you've got the sort of from the
religious right that complains that
they're you know can introduce dangerous
you know thoughts of into people's minds
nobody was killing anybody in the name
of God before video games right well
never happened
yeah atheists there's you know the
people doing this in the 90s writing the
games press did a great job of defending
defending video games against those
charges they've done a much less job
good job in fact they've done no job at
all of defending it against feminists
who are just as wacky and just as crazy
as the old religious right and in fact
the feminists say all the same things
they hate the same things they hate
nudity and violence but all the same
stuff this is why some very clever
Brendan O'Neill who's at wonderful
comest and Britton wrote in The
Spectator of great thing about it was a
provocation but it was it was
interesting about how feminism looks
quite a lot like Islamism in some
regards because it hates the same things
I hates female nudity it's you know any
ask for the same stuff and it has uses
the same language I wrote I did a silly
quiz online in my column about Anita
sarkeesian who is the leading feminist
critic of video games or Jack Thompson
who was the 90s
religious right guy and I just sort of
lined up a load of quotes from each of
them and asked you know you have to go
in here to pick which who said it and no
but nobody got more than 5 out of 10
which is my point same language and it
goes to that that difference it's not
really about left and rights don't worry
bout politics anymore the most important
political distinction in people since
more of our what as more of our lives
move online more of our discourses
online as more people navigate the
internet what the Internet has done to
politics is very interesting it has
turned every major culture war and every
major discussion into a row between
authoritarians want to control how other
people live and libertarians who either
you know want to escape into fantasy
worlds cause they know to escape you
know what was going on their life or
simply classical liberals like me who
believe in freedom of expression freedom
of thought liberty of of idea and and
and believe that it is essential for you
know the good of our species if you like
it if you want to get serious about it
that we can talk about everything openly
and honestly and that there are no no-go
areas I'm what my colleague at bright by
Alan Bukhari cause a cultural
libertarian I'm not a libertarian
politically speaking but I believe that
in culture there should be no boundaries
and that we should be able to explore
everything
video games are assailed on all sides
from the left from the right from
everybody by people who want to restrict
the acceptable limits of a creative
expression I think that's dangerous I
think it's dangerous wherever it happens
I think video
games are the most interesting
entertainment medium in which is
happening now because it is that because
the gamers are the first people who rose
up and said no for the social justice
warriors and it was a horrible and
humiliating defeat for them right so
it's actually interesting and then we'll
move on to feminism specifically but
it's really interesting because this is
sort of the awakening that I now see
happening in our political discussion
people are now hitting on this
libertarian thing and fighting the
authorities Bernie it's Bernie Sanders
it's Trump
it's Faraj and Corbin in the UK all of
the populist political movements on the
left and the right they come from all
over the counter countercultural
anti-establishment libertarian leanings
right now Corbin in the UK is much more
of a socialist he's much more of a
prescriptive kind of guy but his
supporters you know want to be able to
behave terribly and they do behave
terribly just this week they were
spitting on people in the Tory
conference in Manchester they want the
right not just to think terrible things
like I do micro just a cultural liberty
and they want the right to behaved
abominably all of this stuff you know is
it comes from the you know think I think
something we've all known for 10 20
years it's increasing dissatisfaction
alienation from the political and media
relates that a lot of ordinary voters
feel yeah people I think pretty much
everybody feels that regardless I think
they do and even I think we'll get onto
this later
even those of us who work in the media
have quite knifes lives and come from
nice homes and you know and don't really
have much to complain about still feel
that quite acutely and you and I think
are examples of people who are a bit
more alive to that a bit more aware of
the fact that the you know that um
political discourse and cultural
discussion on television has become
really really dull yeah and you've had
people on your show already in the first
right and you've had people on your show
in the first three episodes who are very
insistent about free speech and free
expression and the importance of old
Victorian style classical liberalism but
also the importance of mischief and joy
and a little bit of fun like magic no
Majid namazi
sure who is a great lover of fun and
mischief and loves to tease people who
want to lecture him and bully him and
the leftists who say to him that he's
not a proper Muslim or whatever you know
because he doesn't want to keep women in
burkas or whatever it is right what is
this which that to me seems racist if
you say well he's not being good about
but very well racism but you see we
start away gamergate we do you see where
we ended here your gate oh this is what
this
super I promise yeah the reason
gamergate does this is gamergate is is
the sort of final it's almost at the
final chapter in two decades worth of
internet wars and those internet wars
have been about thought speech culture
politics you name it every community on
the internet and every sub community
within those sites with a four channel
reddit or whatever has a dog in the
fight in gamergate because they all
either have a vested interest in free
speech and anonymity or they have an
interest in protecting the integrity
integrity and creative expression of
certain attainment mediums or their
their individual people who have behaved
terribly on the internet who saw
gamergate as a redemptive opportunity so
if they lined up with you know the women
and went in with these mostly fake
threats about death and rape and all the
rest of it
typical leftist feminist tactics that
don't stack up when you look into them
lining up on one side of that debate was
a way of indicating whether you were for
authoritarianism it was a sort of
confluence of all of these nascent
arguments and wars online and and and
gamergate takes you in these crazy
directions because in a way it's sort of
the most all-encompassing war and the
most all-encompassing event that's ever
happened on the internet because it
brought in everybody all of the old
battles you know something people don't
always realize when you range up the
sides on gamergate there are people who
were involved in wars five years ago
kind of take picking the same sorts of
sides this is that this is the best
example we have yet the most exciting
example culturally we haven't
journalists it's not such a terrible
idea a terrible job of reporting on this
concentrating these fake great threats
conservatives have missed the missed the
huge cultural opportunity here
shamefully so leftist have not even
bothered to make the arguments because
they know their arguments are nonsense
and they focused on the threats this was
such an interesting example of what I
was saying earlier the fact that on the
internet that it's not about left and
right anymore
it's about authoritarians and
libertarians yeah and cultural
libertarians are the rising power and
they're the people who love me they're
the people I think much of your audience
falls into the same bucket actually the
people have Lauren southern the
libertarian current Canadian politician
they love Cathy young a great veteran
journalist of christina hoff sommers at
the American Enterprise Institute Adam
Baldwin the actor but all of the even
Eli Roth the director is making a making
a movie about social justice yeah right
now you know
cultural libertarianism is on the rise
because people are sick of political
correctness people are sick of being
told their racist sexist misogynist
transphobic when they know they're not
once again I think by asking you about
Gabriel we just hit on a zillion we hit
on a zillion topic that is the best I
can do yeah all right so we're gonna
leave it there and I'm sure the
commenters are gonna have a field day
with it which is great so let's talk
about some other stuff so feminism which
you've already enlightened me a bit on
you really really are against feminism
before I let you do your piece now my
sense is that feminism at least the way
it started was that women wanted
equality they wanted the same equality
of opportunity that men had there is no
doubt that most of these roads in our
society have been easier for men I think
you would argue that that's changed now
but so what do you think of the feminist
movement you were just kicked out of the
Amber Rose thought walk well the picture
you paint is perfectly accurate or at
least it was until perhaps 10 maybe 15
years ago so any recently has changed
very recently I think most people
instinctively agree with the equality of
opportunity and equality of access for
women they want women to have the
opportunity to do anything they want to
rise as high as a man if they prepared
to work as hard and put the same amount
of hours in and of course I agree with
that I think everybody agrees with that
that's not what modern intersectional
third wave as it's called feminism is
about which seems to me and I think to a
lot of women too primarily to be about
man hating it is a very angry bitter
profane lesbionic sort of feminism right
to be angry though I mean about we've
known oppressed class don't make you
know equal money as men are the way it's
one of those feminist myths that won't
die basically if you take all of the
earnings of men and all of the earnings
of women are you do a simple bit of
maths then you'll get something like a
77 right what this doesn't take into
account is different choices that women
make doesn't take into account you know
a variety of factors no reputable
economists takes the way to camp
seriously but it's repeated be
you know I mean I we still this we saw
where the stuff comes from just this
week SlutWalk I was kicked out of
journalists for Time magazine reported
that 15,000 people had come out in
support of this [ __ ] walk I was there it
was too like maybe 250 she blathered she
you know started to sort of blame other
people and eventually they changed it to
thousands but was still wrong this sort
of like sloppy ideological reporting and
I'm sorry to say that the most brazen
untruths always come from the left just
like most of the major plagiarism
scandals come from the left because they
believe in narrative over fact this is
how rolling stone happened you know the
the the fake rape in rolling stone it's
how Duke Lacrosse happens it's how you
know all of these things happen because
these were liberal journalists believed
that even if this one's not true it's
very important for us to talk about
right so I'm with you on that because
even with some of my prior guests like
Sam and Margit right this is what
they've you know and they're getting a
receiving end of it you know these these
memes of like you know that's for
whether it's three four or five women
one in three one in four one in five
women are going to get sexually
assaulted on campus which is just
nonsense whether it's the wage gap which
is nonsense
you know these things become established
as part of almost omit they won't become
almost folkloric and right after the
president I mean Obama repeats some of
these statistics but they're not true
and if you look at the work for example
christina hoff sommers I mentioned
earlier the American Enterprise
Institute who very crisply and cleanly
and entertainingly debunks this stuff
well she's great you should I mean she
takes a scalpel to these guys and it's
it's clinical and brilliant to watch it
um none of this stuff stacks up so if
you're trying to make the case that
women have a right to be angry that they
should be angry because women have all
of these in justices well ask you what
are these in justices and every single
one that's given by feminists every
example is given by feminists does not
stand up to scrutiny women are not an
oppressed class in the West there is no
rape culture in the West we don't
celebrate rapists we put them in prison
women don't earn less than men for the
same work that's illegal it is true that
you know because women and mothers there
are consequences when it when you get
into the workplace on that but a woman
is paid the same work as a man so we
know when you when you say there's a way
this confusion between wages and
earnings you know when you say 77 to the
dollar what women here is
well I'm gonna get page 77 cents for a
man's pound no woman has that experience
it doesn't happen you know there's some
women who work part time because they
have children well they have children
what'd you expect you know the important
thing is that we make sure that when
women come back to work after they have
children that they're not disadvantaged
for that now where that's happening
that's wrong but it is not it is not a
problem on the scale of what you know
Sam Harris and Margit will talk about
you know happening to women in the
Middle East right you know and feminists
will never talk to you about this
difficult stuff because they don't want
to be they don't want to be put in the
difficult position of having to rank
Islam versus women right that's where
Western world it's a Western Western
world Western feminism complaining about
man spreading mansplaining this constant
this constant message that men are evil
and broken and wrong toxic masculinity
this is offensive it's irritating it is
wrong and it's destruction all right so
let's let's go right to that you wrote a
piece this week about this about the
shooter in Oregon yeah and your your
piece basically was saying that men are
being abused in the media or so are so
easily dismissed in society that that
they're acting out in in crazy ways and
we have to stop treating yeah man like
what I know and I know a lot of people
on the left for a lot of reasons you're
describing will read something like that
and say you know this is nonsense men
men have all the power
yep I mean what I said was that it at
least part of the reason that some of
these young men are acting out that we
have these shooting these shootings
happening at least some of the reason
for that is the horrible position we've
put men in now you can read every day in
major new media publications that there
is a there is a problem intrinsically
with being a straight white male or just
being a white man that somehow that
gives you privileged access to certain
institutions that you are somehow
problematic it's not the experience of
young men today who go through
university and are one in seven of them
is it who put on Ritalin or adderall
because they are held up to female
beauty female behavior standards it's
not the experience of boys there's a
direct connection between the medication
and the well of course there's of course
of course there is big
Helia Nobby Taylor's behavior standards
of course there is behavior behavior
standards and we're not just doing that
but we're also changing the way that
exams are marked to make them easier for
women because women don't test well in
exams so boys are struggling boys are
falling behind and this is not a
controversial thing everybody knows this
boys are falling horribly behind girls
in education fewer men are going to
university more women graduate go moving
at higher grades in the workplace for
example Cornell study from 2015 showed
that women have a two-to-one advantage
going for the same job just because
everybody is desperate to hire women the
experiences of men growing up now do not
reflect these horrible headlines about
straight white men and frankly I think
progressives have got themselves into a
really weird corner they don't seem to
appreciate the irony of criticizing
somebody for their skin color and their
orientation but they do it anyway right
and they what they would say well this
is the group that's in power so if
they're being well they would strongly
claim that there is a sort of mystical
force and society known as the
patriarchy and what these feminists will
claim is that the patriarchy is
responsible for keeping women down and
all of these crazy expressions like
toxic masculinity whatever flow from
this this tired old ideology about male
power and now as camille paleo that
wonderful dissident feminist critic says
you know if society be left in they're
left in the hands of women we'd still be
living in mud huts thank God for the
patriarchy it's the patriarchy that got
us to the moon it's the patriarchy the
bill the Internet's the patriarchy that
built this floor and the ceiling women
didn't want to do that is the patriarchy
that drives all trucks and a steeple
Jack so you know women I want to do that
stuff either we're perfectly happy to
complain about gender representation
when there aren't enough women when when
there aren't enough women in it in a
particular subject feel for our
arbitrary quotas but we don't make it
the same complain the other way around
men were the ones that were going out
and hunting and women were taking care
of the home so I find that arguments a
little flimsy because I don't know there
are people who say that's not a bad way
to structure society I mean when we
start to break down those gender look
this all comes from the sort of
discredited leftist idea that gender is
socially constructed and Egyptians are
socially constructed right if you're
taught to be a boy or taught to be a
girl rather than having a lot of that
behavior genetic a lot of behavior sort
of encoded in you if you like as a
virtue
by virtue of your chromosomes if you if
gender
performance and it's a social construct
there's no reason why girls can't behave
like boys and boys can't behave like
girls now we're beginning to start to
see that fall apart now one of the ways
in which it falls apart is the
transgender debate we know now now
progressives are telling us that people
can be born with the wrong brain if you
could be born with a female brain and
they must be such a thing as a female
brain so surely you know femininity
can't be a copy a social construct make
your bloody minds up yeah and this was
that you know everybody was saying that
Abby or most sane people I think we're
saying that obviously Rachel Dolezal
couldn't choose to be black she was
white and she this is another shoe she
was created by progressives who said
that blackness was a performance that
you could that blackness was a social
construct that race was know that race
is a social construct of course it isn't
you know we know now because we have the
computer processing power to do it we
know that the you know when we look at
the genome that there are clusters of
clusters of information that map onto
certain geographies in that's in that
statistical sense we know now that race
is real and you know we know from
ordinary people know from the common
sense of our eyes and all years you know
we know that people look different and
behave differently we know that stuff
but progressives for you know a variety
of barmy reasons best known to
themselves have been claiming that's
gender and race as social constructs all
this stuff is starting to fall apart now
is the gender one falling apart I don't
want to belabor this point but the
tenements will you not believe that
people can be trans because III know
some trans people I have no doubt I
didn't say that I what I said what I
said was what I said was transgender
debates very interesting very dangerous
for progressives and they haven't yet
dealt with this if you can be born with
the wrong brain if you can be born if
you cut a few be born a man with a
woman's brain that means there's such a
thing as a woman's brain right so what
what transgender patients will do is
they start hacking away at themselves to
make them but you know an anatomically
more like women so they're you know
somewhere between the two genders by the
end of it right they're not functioning
women but they look a bit more like
women and some of their you know some
things work a bit more like women and
they have the appearance of women and
they say they have a woman's brain if
you can have a woman's brain there is
such a thing as a woman's brain is
there's a biological basis for certain
behavioral differences now you were
asking me about sort of men going out
to forage maybe no bad thing that we let
men be kuru you know be the
hunter-gatherers and women may indeed be
happier focusing on bringing up bring up
children and building a home certainly
the women that I know that are in their
twenties that have been told or
especially in the 30s they've been told
they can have it all they can have a
career they're living in a horrible
apartment they don't like with a cat
they're miserable I hate all their
friends they're not happy people well
they've been you know they've encouraged
to be single encouraged by feminism
particularly to look how they want to
this this fat butt fat positivity that
is another feminist trope is that you
can look like what you want the self
esteem shouldn't depend on what a man
thinks of you well yes it should because
if you want to you know if you want to
settle down with a manual like and have
a nice happy life there are certain
things that men liking women like stay
Finn you know and you may not like it
but it's a fact visual animals right now
some some guys like fat girls but not
many and if you if you're listening to
feminists who are telling you can grow
blue armpit hair and you can burp and
fart and swear you can be Lena Dunham
this disgusting quivering mass of horror
you know and men will like you that's a
lie will not like you'll be alone and
you'll be miserable I think a lot of
people here are gonna say well this is
sort of somehow this is some of your gay
rage or misogyny coming out I don't have
a dog in the fight I don't care I don't
care I don't care if you're thin or fat
as a woman I won't want to [ __ ] you
either don't care like what I want is
for people to be happy and I see people
not being happy because I see that women
are moving in a very very dangerous
direction told lies by wacky far-left
feminists crazies who want to control
other people because they're hurting
inside think a minute minute minute
cases very often it's 30 40 year old
bitter old women trying to lecture
twenty year old girls on how to behave
it's an ugly woman on woman form of
violence if you like modern feminism it
is a nasty thing to watch and I see
women get drawn into this and I find it
sad but there is of course one great
hope and a silver lining to all this
which is that feminism is collapsing in
popularity among women in just a few
years the number of American women who
described themselves as feminists has
gone from 28 to 18% you can read in Vox
right it's not some way that would
advertise sisters
just because of the success of the
movement identify as feminists and they
don't identify as feminists because they
see in feminism what I see which is it
is turned into a bitter nasty ugly
man-hating empty horror show and frankly
you read these blogs like Jezebel which
know which rail against men most women
don't hate men most women don't want to
beat up on people for being straight or
being white or being a male most people
cut like a boyfriend you know so they
see they don't have anything in common
with these angry gender warriors who
want to deny basic human nature and who
make claims and give instructions that
are almost designed to make women
miserable yeah and I think most women
recognize that which is why feminism is
falling off a cliff with women I love
how you wrap up even the things I
disagree with in the in the social
justice warrior prism because that's my
that's my weak spot because I'm so
against that that I have to sort of
acknowledge some of what you're saying
here all right so let's do one more
thing and then and then I want to spend
the whole second half of this really on
one topic specifically I want to about
atheism because it's so boring just a
couple of people wrong in a room being
very angry on the internet so you don't
you almost think that atheists don't
exist no no no lesbians don't exist
arari unfortunately there are four see
there are a so there are a you
acknowledge that there are people aughts
of wrong people in the world you know
and one of the wrong kinds of wrong
people they're atheists now the thing I
forgot fine about a few I don't really
care if somebody believes in God or not
I hope they do I wish they did because I
know quite a nice if they joined me up
there you know in 40 50 years but
there's something up there I've got a
first-class ticket she loves me I'm very
confident reason I the reason I have a
go a theist is because it's fun because
they're so thin-skinned they're like
come they're like libertarians or
they're like cyclists or Liberal
Democrats in the UK or you know any
other sort of war feminists in fact you
know they're so easy to wind up I mean
you know how many atheists is it take to
change a light bulb before you've even
given the punchline people are furious
and there's a reddit thread about it and
they're just so much fun and but why
would you be going after the people that
it's easy to go after I mean every poll
shows
like the most hated my please please
these these people have some of the most
celebrated public intellectuals on their
side Richard Dawkins the late
Christopher Christopher Hitchens these
people have huge public intellectuals on
their side military militant atheism if
you like atheism is the trendiest thing
in the world every journalist is an
atheist everybody in the media is an
atheist no you're never going to get
somebody laugh at you or look at you
weirdly for announcing you're an atheist
you know it's you're a Christian or a
Muslim or a Jew you know all sorts of
bad things happen to you right nobody
nobody looks at you funny except me I'm
probably a person if you announce that
you're an atheist because you know this
is this is the this is a privileged
group in society that I find it funny to
take the mickey out of because they are
so touchy this is interesting because so
when you were talking about gamergate
part of what you liked is that there was
this groundswell coming up from the
bottom fighting this authoritarian and I
think when people oh that again now but
but I don't think we're there yet I get
that angle and this is what all my
friends on the right say that the
religious now are the ones being
oppressed and Christians are being I
wouldn't go supposed to say I wouldn't
go as far as to say oppressed saying
it's basically crazies is wrong I
wouldn't go as far as to say Christians
are an oppressed class in this country
because I don't think there are many
oppressed classes in this country I
would think maybe black people still
that's probably the only one in this
country I don't think they're an
oppressed class but I do think I've been
very ashamed of my fellow my fellow
homosexuals in the way that they have
behaved toward Christians and some of
the media circuses that have happened
recently I have it so I can I can go
with you on that deeply deeply horrified
to watch gay people treat Christians as
gays were treated Feb barely two decades
ago I do think there's some value though
but I do I have noticed you know I did a
David Webb who's gonna be a guest on our
show in a couple weeks from Fox News and
on Sirius XM I was on his show when gay
marriage was was being passed by the
Supreme Court law was being struck down
today Shane yeah we'll get to that too
in a second but what he said to me just
literally I think it was the first day
it was the day that it happened was that
we should really already start being we
should start policing the gays to make
sure we don't start a pressing Christian
but is
don't have to give it a little time
don't we have to let gays have a little
time to work with to be bullies no
before suddenly no no we don't need to
give gay people any time to be bullies
they have shown and this is it this is
what you this is something that I always
find interesting about people how they
behave when they enter the corridors of
power how people behave when they are
granted the status that they have asked
for for so long
when gays are finally not just equal
society but held up as models of
Paragons of virtue I mean you read goryl
BuzzFeed you would think that being gay
was some kind of moral objective that
being gay was somewhere so you know it
was better than being straight in some
way you know I'm gonna say perhaps
discuss the show what I think on that
but you know it but it seems like a
weird proposition and therefore the face
of it but if you read BuzzFeed or Vox or
Gawker you'll get that impression no I
don't think gay people deserve any time
to be bullies to settle into you know
their position or in authority and I
think it does gay people a lot of damage
to see these bitter hysterical nasty
Queens bullying and lecturing and
hectoring ordinary decent law-abiding
people of faith and I thought it was
utterly deplorable when that couple who
staged a renewal of their vows they
didn't even have a wedding but they
staged a renewal of their vows cuz I
already had the wedding solely it seemed
to get a photo opportunity with pizzas
for memories Pizza which they tricked
this Christian Christian pizzeria into
catering their thing now set aside the
horror I think most gay people at home
will feel about pizza I've told your
cameraman to shoot me from here set that
aside how hollow and bitter what a
terror what an awful kind of human being
you would have to be to turn your
special day on a day of appreciation and
celebration between you and your family
the people that you love into a gps tone
right so people that you think of that
you know you've gay people in many cases
turn themselves as the worst kind of
grandstanding bigot no they do not need
time to settle in they're very much
settled it right so I'm sort of with you
on that because I I do understand that
look they purposely did this for a
Christian Baker had they went to it they
got to they got to an Orthodox Jewish
Baker or or a Muslim Baker and force
them to do this the media wouldn't have
nearly the fun that they had
but so just wrapping this around atheism
then we're gonna do everything else
we're gonna do is gay for the rest of
this after after this final question I
know it's exhausting positions of power
do you think that I don't see atheists
in any position yes there are a couple
cool thought of atheists out there right
positions of power now it's about what
do you think social cashing but so what
do you think that the main the average
atheist in which in a theatre is only
brought together by the lack of the
belief in a deity no I mean that brought
together by you know sort of wispy
facial hair terrible spectacles of long
ginger ponytails terrible terrible
thin-skinned natural sort of demeanor
you know to hair-trigger temper these
are the primary characteristics of an
atheist socks and sandals those terrible
cheap chinos if that's what you want to
respond to then go right ahead but you
know Kath Catholics all the best outfits
you know rich older men in dresses
what's not to love we know if you want
if you're if you want a sense of style
then you become a Muslim or or a
Catholic um no I mean look a theists are
it is not just acceptable but it is the
norm in any metropolitan city in Europe
or in America to be an atheist it is
normal to be an atheist people look at
you weird if you're not right so what's
the problem with it's funny to like the
person you just want to make fun of them
even I enjoy making fun of them I enjoy
making fun out of everybody I don't
making fun of you I enjoy making fun
with myself I make fun out of myself all
day on my Twitter feed that's what
that's what provocateurs do all right
well I can accept that I will grant you
that part I won that one that little
section but I did well you can have one
hour fun I want to spend the rest of the
time talking about a whole bunch of gay
stuff mm-hm because I mentioned on the
show a week and we've done five of these
here yeah I think this is our fifth
episode since we've been with Aurra I've
only watched once mentioned anything
about being gay I don't I don't make it
an issue unless it's relevant in quite a
stretch it is what it is I mean believe
me I'm gay
I'm married you don't mean I'm married
to dude pretty gay okay but I I don't
smile a actually okay so you're selling
out I know selling out selling out to
the hetero people institutions yes yes
gay married my god all right any more
awful so before we do that portion of
this it's hilarious the the the liberal
here married one and the conservative
one is the one railing against marriage
it's look I just think it's sad you know
I want heterosexuals to come back to
institution of marriage I want them to
realize that it's a good thing I want
them to become more socially
conservative in that regard I don't want
gay people being growing up so we're
just gonna go all in on this I'll
reverse my question so go go alright I
don't think being gay is particularly
fun and I wouldn't choose it for any of
my children for example I think Sally
Kohn who said that they like said that
she'd like to have a gay child I thought
it was deplorable and sadistic and
incredibly selfish so meaning what if
Safire self has come to a place really
what she said was if she could if she
said what she said was if she could pick
she'd rather have a gay kid and I
thought that was a deplorable thing to
say because what what secure lies might
may have child's life so much more
miserable but but it's getting easier
every day what don't you think that when
how will you oh gee you don't ask all
right well you really don't a propagate
oh yeah terrible failure as a gay man so
lady what point be it's a lot it's a lot
easier for you than it was for a 30-year
old gay man ten years ago and it's gonna
be way sure but but so there's the
normalcy that no you're you're confusing
to even things there's a sort of
practical ease with which a gay person
can go through life because there is no
longer the entrenched homophobia if you
like in certain wider society the the
the fact that gay people can have a
relationship and live together and
nobody really cares and I don't think
anybody cares anymore
well I've said that for a long time I'm
so sick of talking about it which is why
I don't all I wanted was equally I just
want to be treated as SH I didn't know I
think I better than anybody I think gay
people getting married and in
relationships is a shame because I quite
like the dissident a naughty sort of
aspect of gay life and I think that it's
you know
part of my gay privilege to be able to
tumble out of a nightclub at 3:00 a.m.
with you know doorman on my arm and you
know popped off my face but you do that
while still know people like you people
like you getting married getting a dog
living in a little house you know yet
you know horrible horrible no
self-respecting gays home enough to feed
something like that I mean I don't know
what you're doing really what do you
didn't keep coming home and comments
telling who's cooking tonight I should I
do all right then awful awful yeah but
keep that alive but really do you really
believe that I get it I get what you're
doing here I get it no I do you think
there's some value in this because I
think that and I think it's because gay
look how my sexuality is a dissident
aberrant sexuality I mean that in in a
morally neutral sense you just mean it
to the other I don't know I don't mean
that
um in using the term what do you mean
notice here porn I said let's let's set
the religion stuff aside because they
were gonna get into a rabbit hole but
let's just say you know how much they
try to you is not the norm it is an
aberrant sexuality that mother nature
made you for a variety of reasons right
there's some evidence that people with
higher IQs are more likely to engage in
different sexual appetites that was one
of the reasons why gay people have
disproportionately higher IQs and one of
the reasons I think for example that
gays should get back in the closet
because we're making society stupid Oh
cuz gay people aren't breeding anymore
whereas previously you could you would
have a marriage with a woman and you
would have a couple of kids and gay men
were still in the gene pool right now
they've taken themselves out and they
don't have their own biological children
anymore like you've got your sort of two
to five percent of the smartest men in
population on breeding in what people
keep saying us are we gonna have kids
anything I don't know but we're gonna
keep it if you do you should have your
own biological children because you're
smarter than most people I thought we
were being serious all right yeah no
okay yeah all right it doesn't work when
you yeah I just you know it's kind of a
silly thing but it's certainly true the
the sort of average of intelligence
society started chugging outwards slowly
but it is definitely being [ __ ] if
five to ten percent
yeah two to five percent rather you know
if the smartest people in society aren't
breeding anymore so anyone I think
that's a silly but I do think there's a
shame
when as a gay is one of those people
that Mother Nature has selected to be
different and to test stuff out and to
push the boundaries
we'll come on to in a minute in respect
to free speech I think that you sort of
buy into precisely the sort of the sort
of socially conservative institutions
which I love and I recognize the
building blocks of society recognizes a
homosexual not scale it shouldn't have
them as a homosexual you should
recognize that your your evolutionary
function is to experiment with different
models of things right and one of the
ways in which gay culture and society is
done is the sort of sex mad hedonism
that I enjoy that I think that I'm sorry
that you did you don't have anymore
because you have this horrible mother
people life well I've done but you're
you're combining eighteen different
things here so first up the I sense that
a lot of what you're saying is you just
you long for the day probably when you
were 22 and you were out every night and
doing all kinds of drugs and having all
right so with last week right long for
that day and a lot of a lot of
mainstream gay look I live in West
Hollywood I see what the I think a
Suffolk I know ring so I think gay
people have become very very dull but is
that a shame isn't that no it's not good
because with Seth we are of equality no
why would we want to be equal we were
already superior why would we want to go
down to equality it's absurd to me we
already know we gay people and we're
mother nature makes their mistakes and
makes her great discoveries it'll be
great all the gay geniuses in history
you know whether it's Turing or you know
Abe Lincoln reportedly or you know all
the other Roman emperors you know look
at what mother nature does with these
aberrant special people at the top end
of the intelligence and sort of
dissident you know scale those those
those what Steve Jobs are call the crazy
ones right and this is why the tech and
gaming industry is disproportionately
gay and trans because it's those special
people that have brains wired slightly
differently from others who can make
those great leaps yeah who consider you
know consider problems differently who
are generally more creative and more I'm
with you on that
music warring with you are a as why is a
member of the gamemaster race would you
want to slump down to the level of
heterosexuality because you should have
the option oh yes yes I'm not telling
you what to do if you want the option
what I'm telling you is you made the
wrong choice okay so you don't think
that a lot of these people that are
doing all the things that look I did
them you know you all of those things
sex drugs all that I did all that you
know do mean I don't I look back on much
of it very fondly actually people call
me a traitor to my sex rather you're the
traitor I don't think my agent would
allow me to tell you what I do but you
know why don't you try so the things
that you I think you're looking at this
in this nostalgic way of fun there was
dissent
but wouldn't you trade some of that look
when you think about all the people that
are having promiscuous sex numbers gonna
directly go down because I don't care
about this it's actually choices it's as
easy as who gives a [ __ ] I don't care
about that what I care about is the fact
that this is a serious point it's not
just the fun living those fun lifestyles
and I mentioned Steve Jobs early only
said that much moment many of his
innovations come from the faculty took
LSD right gay people have a license to
experiment a license to explore it's one
of the reasons why gay culture which is
so so to do with exploring boundaries
pushing the limits of acceptable
discourse and speech and thought right
sit in to visit of boring domesticity
it's precisely with those put those
horizon broadening experiences which you
have given up as a as a you know as a
housewife or a house husband or whatever
I think two weeks are having home-cooked
meals watching people call me a trace in
my sexuality please no look I think that
the gay people are one of the groups in
which mother nature one of the groups uh
mother nature has given license to go
wild and that's why so many great
artists and inventors and authors and
all over been gay lesbian whatever right
because we have a unique
and unique opportunity an insight into
the fringes into the that put that edge
of culture that makes stuff interesting
we have an ability to push further than
rather than ordinary people can we can
say things they can't say for example I
can go on TV and say all manner of
outrageous things about feminism
only because I'm armed sexual right let
me ask anything do you think I could get
away with those same things because
obviously we have a little different
effect people always say to me you don't
seem gay which I know you wouldn't be
you I mean it's kind of may say it as a
compliment kind of my thing right people
know that I'm gonna do this all right
social justice proof it's very difficult
to argue that a flamboyant homosexual
who never shuts up about how about you
know black boyfriend's is in any way
bigoted right so it gives me I've
established myself in the public mind
the public imagination in a way that you
haven't so a lot of that ironically
that's what this is about you like while
you were in some ways rail against these
people that want to be protected like
the feminists or whatever you do like I
enjoy using their weapons against them
and I'm perfectly happen Tuesday open
guess I wish I didn't have to I don't
want to be trolling people for my whole
life of course I don't you know but I
would much rather it were the case that
everybody had free open frank discussion
but at the media as currently
constituted if you want to push forward
the discussion outside the ROMs of
academia in the public square talking to
ordinary people for example I wrote for
a publication is sort of mid brow mid
market publication for everyone the sort
of digital media equipment the tabloid
newspaper I want talk to everybody and
to push debate forward in those
environments you do have to play by the
rules and some of those rules are based
on identity politics which I think are
absurd and obscene stupid yeah but I
will certainly play along with them if
it helps because it's so long as as
progressives and feminists refused to
have a debate on the basis of the facts
and insist on having a debate you know
the basis of identity and skin color
instead fine I can beat them in that too
you know I'm happy to beat you on any
playing field on any battlefield you
choose they've chosen identity politics
I can beat them there if they ever want
to come to the table and debate properly
I'll beat them there so that I think I
think you're onto something interesting
there there you'll use their weapons I
don't like their weapons and you're
lying that you're using their wits them
I think in a cheeky sense where you
where you know that you're there's a
wink to what you know anybody reads my
Twitter feed knows this you know I know
exactly what's up I know what's going on
but they still lose anyway
so so part of the reason why I wanted to
do this is because I do find that again
while we come from different we
literally come from different countries
but come from different political parts
of this but you really at least an
American media only get one gay only one
gay gets out there and it's the Bravo
gay that's either on TV because they're
a fashionista or they're a sidekick to
one of the Housewives or they're somehow
involved in pop culture or something
like that or every now and again someone
can break free like an Anderson Cooper
but then sort of have to be completely
asexual right never talk about their
life and I think this is sort of
interesting because we both break that
that paradigm yes and I think it's
probably because we are cultural
libertarians I would certainly describe
myself as one I think you probably I
hope you'd agree with that I think that
we are those sorts of insurgent
countercultural new media personalities
we exist you may not like to hear this
but we exist on a spectrum with people
like Trump and n Coulter more probably
I'm a lot more on the serious end of it
simply in tapping into ordinary people's
frustrations with the limits and
absurdities of you know what they see on
broadcast television and what they read
in the newspapers there is an
alternative way of having a discussion
which is more honest and more more I
mean this kind of thing could not happen
on broadcast television for example and
that's a problem that's a problem for
the media it's one of the reasons
they're exactly one of the reasons
everybody hates them you know and I
think we both are taking advantage of
that fact as far as the sexuality goes
what I find interesting about you know a
liberal and conservative homosexual
agreeing on so much about
authoritarianism is that well from from
my point of view of six homosexuality is
where we experiment and you know drag
queen culture for example is all about
pushing the boundaries of acceptable
language and thought we see the threats
to freedom of speech for example we see
the authoritarian threat over coming
over the horizon a long time before
anybody else and we're in a position to
warn other people about it and there's a
very serious point about this which is
not just that you know transsexuals to
hate drag queens which is one front in
this sort of progressive fracturing
because drag queens loves you know this
sort of no-holds-barred Joan Rivers
style comedy which you know is the
essence of of gay identities that are
pushing those boundaries and
in transgender people who have got a
fallen into this authoritarian mode hate
that kind of stuff it's not just it's
not just about that it's not about our
community fracturing if you like but
it's also that we see some of the
serious consequences to these
infringement saan on culture because of
course politics is downstream from
culture and what becomes not
unacceptable and politics becomes
unacceptable to say what becomes
unacceptable in culture becomes
unacceptable in politics and we
recognize and we see the warning signs
here so we're sort of the canary in the
coalmine yes I think gamers did this too
you know I think gamers and gays have
very very similarly because gamers are
marginalized people in many cases
disproportionately ethnic minority just
fortunately gauge disproportionately
transgender in my experience often
marginalized personalities often people
who are retreating into video games
maybe because they earthquakes social
skills often very bright brilliant kind
of autistic
you know methodical very male brilliant
minds and very funny and but sometimes I
know there were social skills and in
that way they're quite similar to gays
because they had a occupy a fairly
unique position in the in the social
hierarchy of society and I think gamers
did in their own industry what gay
people ought to be doing in public life
which is precisely that being a canary
in the corner saying for example that
the sort of nannying hectoring language
policing that's happening in progressive
media today is a problem it's a problem
because I mean the first signs are the
policing of gay sexuality there's a
piece in in The Daily Beast I think that
said that some men who express a racial
preference on their Grindr profile are
racist now it's obviously an absurd
thing to say it's completely stupid and
it was some idiot middle-class white
woman who decided that she was going to
police gay sexuality today just as we
you know just as we were getting to a
position of Tolerance suddenly that
people you know someone coming at coming
over the horizon to police gay sexuality
it's happening for two reasons
one gay men have high status in society
they've become very Molly cold very
celebrated in the media so they've sort
of acquired a kind of privilege and when
the left you know the left is constantly
engaged in the business of ranking
people according to their oppression
rating and gay men don't score very well
on in those games because we have money
and we're you know we've basically
become another kind of white man for
right so you would say that basically
the progressives or as I'm now calling
them the regressives basically you're
done with the gays yes yes exactly the
world game since they were like we're
all four you know you know they've got
your gay marriage and now you're gonna
find increasingly that they come off to
you and they're gonna come after you
because you're being too racially
insensitive they're gonna come after you
because use the wrong pronouns they're
gonna come after you absurdly and
brilliantly for misogyny you know I mean
people people make arguments to me
sometimes and they say and it's it's not
as credible in your case but I can
understand how they construct the
argument as bonkers as is they make
arguments they basically boil down to
you're such a misogynist you went gay
you know you hate women so much I can
tell why you why you sleep with men now
happens to be that I do you think
there's a large element of choice in my
sexual orientation although that goes
entirely against a progressive consensus
will do a whole nother show yeah but
it's an extraordinary thing that they
now coming off the gay people for being
misogynistic for being racist or sorts
you're no longer of any use to your own
side right they have used you they have
put your wedding ring on your finger
they have domesticated you like they
would a dog like you did your dog they
have put you in they have they have made
sure you got the right politics that you
say the right things in public they have
domesticated and delineated you know
sort of useful liberal gay idiots and
put them all in little ghettos in cities
like the Castro and West Hollywood and
now you are the product and the and the
chattel of the liberal right so I know
both since Y you you don't mean me
specific no I do know what do you mean
you suppose you know that I stand for
into this no but you know I stand
against the sort of gay marriages away
but controlling gay pee right but I
suspect that along the way if you met
the right person you would want to marry
that person for all the remarried no I
might move them into the West Wing but I
wouldn't marry them okay so we do have
to wrap up here and we could have done
three hours here and we'll do this again
for sure at this point yeah I want to
get to this this piece that has been the
through line to everything we've been
discussing here this this authoritarian
left this this regressive piece where
there have no problem relentlessly I
look I could use the example of the gay
rights groups here in America you know
glad or the HRC who will relent
we'll attack the pizza makers
relentlessly but we'll say nothing when
gays are thrown off the roof in Iran in
Iran right and wrong kind of gays speak
out you know the only cut there is there
is a source of person in America today
so there's a sort of person in America
today who is just a homosexual
discriminated against its gay
conservatives it was much more difficult
to admit you're a gay conservative than
you admit you're gay you meet you're gay
you get slaps on the back you get
applause you get all hose me prove you
know if all of the sick all of the
social signaling about being homosexual
is positive with one exception but if
you're a conservative other gays the gay
establishment and British Fidelis wrote
an amazing essay about this in out
magazine it score something like in the
rain everybody should read it you know
it explains how the gay establishment
which is basically now done with gays
and is sort of a self-perpetuating set
of institutions to push leftist
socialist principles got nothing to do
gay rights anymore will treat you as
what you would call an Uncle Tom in in
race terms you know I have never in my
career as a purposeful provocateur I
don't play the victim on Twitter or in
my columns because you know I think you
should if you should take as well as you
give a rule a rule all gay people learn
quite early in life but you think that
one thing I did that shifting it's a
rule we learned quite early no it's you
know I think you should build it's
better tickets give it and I never play
the victim but I've never had so much
really poisonous vitriolic nastiness as
from other gays who think that my
politics are wrong and it's wonderful
what did the ultimate success here be
you know I've been arguing for a while
now that by gay marriage being legal now
in America in the long term you actually
help the Republicans because this was
such an idiotic issue for so many people
to have to vote the idea that I had to
vote on not that not that it was the
deciding factor but it was I had to vote
on whether I could get married it's a
[ __ ] nonsensical and and painful and
pathetic way to vote so I actually think
ultimately this may turn into a net win
for the Republicans because I'm not sure
days I'm not sure that's the case
everything about this and I caught it
minority wars the way in which you know
if the last ten years was about setting
men and women against each other the
next ten years about all sons of other
minorities I mean you know in the
Hispanic population in the u.s. who are
not encumbered by the guilt of slave
become the the demographic majority
you're going to see some pretty brutal
policing in places like Ferguson you
know because they don't have the same
kind of white middle-class guilt about
about you know black lives matter they
won't you know Hispanic mayor's in in
barely a few generations are not going
to be paying multi-million dollar
settlements to black families they're
gonna be sending police in with guns you
know it's it's there's all sorts of
horrible things on the horizon and it's
driven by the identity politics to the
left which are crumbling but not fast
enough
my serious point about all of this is
that cultural libertarianism which I
keep banging on about which I think
there's always sort of what we've been
talking about but yeah it's a word that
I'm glad is catching on with people can
we just I know you named a few of them
but yeah but it from the article that I
saw on Breitbart I thought it was a
brilliant article will link to it it
wasn't running by the way but yeah but
can we just name a couple of these
people I know you named a few of us so
I'm but Bill Maher was including Bill
Maher Bill Maher's in there Chris Rock
is in there even though he does rely a
lot on his on his blackness as a source
of his comedy he no no he is somebody
for example he's spoken up about the
political correctness certain colleges
on college campuses and says he won't
perform to students anymore because
they're too touchy right I think he
understands this I think Eli Roth the
the horror director Adam Baldwin who
serves a sort of fantasy actor and he's
in love with the gamergate stuff and
then you've got the way these things
normally work is you've got sort of an
guard of hell racers like me and Katie
Hopkins in the UK and kalter perhaps
here now that all those those three
happened to be right-wing but I don't
think it's I don't think you can play
well that that I don't think you can
place people on the political spectrum
and that's why I wonder you mentioned
some of the names because what I liked
about the article was that these people
were from all over them I think the
hellraisers tend to be conservative
today simply because the establishment
is liberal right I think that's why then
further behind that you've got the more
politically ambiguous figures like
Christina Hoff Sommers at the American
Enterprise Institute or Cathy young
feminist journalist who aren't so easy
to place politically Cathy's definitely
a liberal I think Christine or Christine
is a registered Democrat in fact you
know but who nonetheless recognize the
excesses and they in the wake of the
chaos created by the hellraisers are
people like me kind of you know winding
people up and and being you know sort of
viciously teasing people are considered
to be you know dangerous and damaging
and you're throwing bombs no no I
believe all of it
I believe all of it but perfectly you're
happy to accept that I will say it the
most provocative way possible because I
think the only responsible the only
appropriate response to outraged culture
has to be outrageous you know if you're
going to tell me that I can't make jokes
about about skin color I will come back
at you you know with with ten puns about
me being obsessed with black penises or
whatever you know for the record you
brought a six foot six black pornstars i
hired it i hired a black porn star just
because it would annoy the right people
to be my bodyguard because i get bit I
get death and bomb threats everywhere I
go I don't make a big song and dance
about except a laugh how stupid is when
I don't leave any feminists bomb threats
ever gonna be credible they can't even
tie their own shoelaces together let
alone wire a detonator I'm not worried
about getting blown up by feminists what
I what I am worried about is the
chilling effect that they have on free
speech and might just get back to the
point yeah gay people I think and I
think this is was something in which you
and I United having privileged access if
you like to you know the the limits of
acceptable speech and discourse there's
that great that great drag queen joke
you know which I love from from Britain
which get always gets shocks and
national newspaper wouldn't let me
publish which was she comes on stage and
says you like my new hair it's called
the Whitney black and died in the bath
and we were horrified by the gate gave
you will live and love though you know
that sort of stuff
and we see before everybody else you
know which is what the serious
consequences if this is a chilling
effect on free speech can be on those
consequences are there's you know the
sum total of human human knowledge and
whatever you notice origins because love
Jay s mill classical liberal is
unconscionable to modern feminism they
don't believe some of the central tenets
of you know on which British society was
built this is dangerous stuff it's
dangerous stuff because of what's
happening on universities too I mean
just look at the sorts of you know look
at the the feminist hegemony you know
Women's Studies departments that you
know that run rampant on campuses at
Yale I don't know if I hope this is true
and I'm not
miss remembering this but I saw
something you know DeRay McKesson the
black lives matters guy is teaching a
course at Yale and defensive looting you
know all this kind of stuff this is a
weird crazy so I tweeted
but the the women's studies suffered um
you know in many decent universities is
scary it you know it's denying human
knowledge is making people in this stuff
makes it regard it's not you're not just
talking about women's studies though
because this is coming from all over the
place like Berkeley protesting Bill
Maher coming it's restive ISM generally
I have I've just seen I'm supposed to
speak at USC tomorrow night and I've
just seen you know this horrendous blog
post from somebody who says that I'm a
sort of a misogynistic hate speech
merchants because I made a joke about I
don't know what it was it's probably
some joke like you know feminist Barbies
just come out when you pull the cord it
says math is hard let's lie about rape
you know I had some joke like that you
know and they and they paint me out of
some sort of misogynistic harasser to
take away and that that's really where I
sort of wanted to end this with you
because yeah we can everything I've
tried to do with the show so far is show
that you could disagree with people and
we can we can go back and argue the the
tenants of feminism or whether I think
you're right or wrong about men being
oppressed or the gay marriage thing all
those things but but allow the
conversation to happen and I think
that's what happening and that's what
the cultural libertarians they were
talking about are trying to do right
we're trying to have the conversation so
I appreciate you coming in and I want to
thank my guest Milo you're not police
for dropping by you can check out his
work over at Breitbart comm follow them
on Twitter it's at Nero I by the way
make sure to tag me and all the hate
tweets because I know there's gonna be a
lot of them it's at Rubin report and
we'll do this again next week
[Music]